Bob aduba Minister of Economy finances
as a Senegal I'm a dooba Minister of
Economy and Finance of Senegal
antonio guterres secretary general de
nasi onus Unitas Antonio Guterres
secretary-general of the United Nations
Jim Yong Kim Presidente Delbanco mundial
Jim Yong Kim president of the World Bank
christine lagarde director aquarium -
del voto monetary Oh international
Christine Lagarde managing director of
the International Monetary Fund
guy embroider directeur général de la
organización Internacional de trabajo
guy rider general director of the
International Labour Organization
Roberto Acevedo director general de la
organización mundial de el comercio
Roberto Acevedo managing director of the
World Trade Organization theaters are
the norm giving issues director general
deal organization mondiale de la salud o
Tedros an enormous general director of
the World Health Organization Luis
Alberto Moreno Presidente Delbanco inter
americano de sorrows Oh Luis Alberto
Moreno president of the inter-american
Development Bank uncle Maria secretary
okay Nadal they're organized Oh Bella
Sunil the Asaro so economical Secretary
General of the Organization for Economic
Cooperation and Development
Victor Rico secretary Oh general del
Banco de desarrollo de américa latina
vector rico secretary-general of the
Development Bank of Latin America
mark carney presidente del consejo de
habilidades inin serie Makani
chairperson of the Financial Stability
Board
señor Presidente de los Estados Unidos
de America Donald Trump the President of
the United States of America Donald
Trump
[Applause]
yeah well señor Presidente la nación
Argentina Orisha Macri Cano
representantes drop Isis invitados yo
revenues mas internationalize dama pour
concrete Allah presenting Stan SIA a
todo muchísimo gracias
good morning I would like to invite you
to start taking a seat so we invite the
press in for them to take the pictures
sit down and so we can call in the press
for the occasion
and you will see tonight and you will
see tonight at the theater my idea
others production Murray my idea
good morning everyone once again I'd
like to welcome you dear colleagues and
special guests and I would also like to
thank you for being in Buenos Aires this
is the first g20 summit in South America
and it's been 10 years since the heads
of state and government of the g20 met
for the first time gathered in the
United States in the spirit of creating
this mechanism this dialogue forum which
made it possible at that time to prevent
a worsening of the international
financial crisis in the past years
changes in social political and economic
circumstances both globally and within
our countries have led to doubts being
expressed with regard multilateral
mechanisms including the g20 countries
regarding the way to individually tackle
the challenges and address global
opportunities therefore although the
agenda that brings us together today is
different I would like to ask us to act
with the same sense of urgency as in
2008 in a diverse world multiple
protagonists each with their own history
and cultures of the g20 is to foster
dialogue while respecting differences
and encouraging actions based on shared
interests let me say as you well know
this summit is an unprecedented event in
our country never in a history have we
had so many leaders at the same time in
our country and we see this as a gesture
of support and an acknowledgement of the
presence
performance Argentina is exhibiting
lovely especially after so many years of
isolation here we lead us meet face to
face we speak candidly ratifying common
ground while managing disagreements
after year for a decade now this would
be able to lay the foundations consensus
for the next 10 years it's a huge task
at hand we are all witnesses to profound
changes and changes taking place in our
societies changes which have accelerated
in recent years especially in the last
ten and five years changes in production
across citizens in behaviors and customs
in the way we communicate along with
other advances such as in nanotechnology
virtual reality robotics 3d printing all
of which those and creates opportunities
for progress but it also challenges many
of categories today a citizen in 30 days
receives more information than what they
would have received over the course of
the whole lifetime 30 years ago so 30
days as opposed to yes this means that
people have become rich in information
and millionaires in terms of
expectations which I think clearly
signals the level of the challenge today
and we need to rise to that challenge
many people look at us and how doubts
regarding these summits and what they
good for and it is our duty to show to
the world that today global challenges
require global responses problems such
as the future of work
Limor climate change issues that we
can't resolve on our own each of us I
would like to invite us all to work
together to take advantage of the
mechanisms available to us today and to
discuss to discuss what are the
mechanisms we may need in order to
continue to offer coordinated responses
I mean the way I see it the solution as
we saw in a retreat is done dialogue and
the way of pushing the limits of the
possible on the understanding that each
country will have its own preferences
values and interests but we all do agree
on something that we want to sustainable
development and we assume the
responsibility of chairing the g20
convinced that we need to make a
contribution and that we can make a
contribution to International
Cooperation to multilateralism and to
global governance
we've already held over 50 meetings
all around the country as we're a
federal country and we are proud of each
of our regions of the talent of a
peoples when their opportunities to
drive the natural resources and their
cultural heritage
take this opportunity as well to thank
all margin times have taken part to make
it possible to welcome you all to this
major event and I would also like to
thank the residents of Buenos Aires who
I agreed to tackle the challenge of
moving around the city while we have a
meeting consensus fair and sustainable
development these days we'll be dealing
with several topics such as a future
work infrastructure for development a
sustainable food future financial
stability climate sustainability
and international trade among others
this is a people centered agenda with a
forward-looking view by nature I have
always been nice but especially after
this year of work with my team and with
the support of all of you being able to
see that we've reached a very
substantial consensus as enshrined in a
ministerial communication the action
plans agreed upon amongst all of us
however it is clear that consensus
cannot be built from one day to the next
it is a process with progress and
setbacks and which will continue even
after the g20 but it's even better when
our commitments translate into concrete
actions that improve the well-being of
our people at the southernmost g20 ever
held invite us all to give a clear
message to the world to the fact that
here together we can chart a development
horizon one with shared responsibilities
a full commitment to gender equality
with unity in diversity remembering
someone I've always admired this year he
would have been a hundred years old and
he saw that by 2030 we could end poverty
and he was always an advocate of
dialogue so thank you once again for
your presence here I deeply appreciate
it and we shall now begin our first
session in a couple of minutes thank you
very much